what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it's been a while since we've heard
anything about the Fantastic Four
however it looks like Marvel Studios is
indeed on the move the writer strikes
are now over and we've heard that the
Fantastic Four script has been Rewritten
we've also heard on top of that that the
Rewritten script has gone out to some
particular actors and it seems like
Marvel Studios is really iron one
particular actor to play Mr Fantastic of
the Fantastic Four as far as whose storm
is concerned as far as we know Vanessa
Kirby is our Sue storm she is our
Invisible Woman of the MCU and a new
report today tells us that Marvel
Studios might already have the entire
cast locked down if not they definitely
do have Vanessa Kirby lockdown for Sue
storm as they are starting tests for the
Fantastic Four Marvel Studios has begun
testing for the film so it's starting
the production for the Fantastic Four is
beginning despite all of the strikes
that are happening or I should say have
happened partially because the writer
strikes over and we've recently heard
news that sag after is going to be
meeting with the studios and streamers
so hopefully the strike for the actors
in soon as well then they can really get
the ball going but fortunately for us
and for Marvel Studios the writer
strikes are over and they don't exactly
need the actors right away to begin
pre-production plus the rider strikes
being over is a big thing because now
they can continue to work on the script
adjust it change whatever they need and
what is most likely going to happen is
that when the Riders come back the
studio heads are probably going to have
some new ideas and they'll have to sit
down and they'll have to all share their
ideas the writers are probably going to
have some new ones as well so hopefully
after the strikes are finally over and
everybody is back to work there will be
a lot of great new ideas shared with the
studio and with the writers as well now
there have been some delays which we
talked about yesterday but it looks like
the Fantastic Four are still on track we
have a new report today from Umberto
Galas from the rap and he States Little
Nugget about Marvel Studios news he says
they are testing lenses today at
Panavision for the Fantastic Four so
this is big it means they are getting
ready to actually start filming not too
long from now and you know what that
means as soon as they start filming for
this we are going to find out who the
Fantastic Four members are they're not
going to be able to keep people from
getting set photos because they always
happen unless they literally film
everything inside which they totally
could but unless they do that it's gonna
get out and even if they film inside
somebody is going to leak who the
members are of the Fantastic Four which
actors are playing which characters so
hopefully and probably Marvel Studios is
going to announce beforehand before they
start filming who the Fantastic Four
cast actually is and since they are
about to start filming it seems like
that announcement is pretty imminent
right now now if you're not aware
Panavision is a camera and Studio
company so right now Marvel Studios is
over at Panavision at their headquarters
and they're testing the lenses of how
they want to shoot now normally I would
say that perhaps they would have an
actor there from the show but since the
writer strikes are happening right now I
don't believe so so they're more than
likely right now just testing the looks
and here's the very interesting part
about this the reason the lenses might
matter a little bit more for the
Fantastic Four film is because of what
we've heard recently some recent plot
details about the Fantastic Four one is
that the movie might be set back in time
in the 1960s in this case they might use
different types of lenses to kind of
give it a different feel not such a
modern feel through a very modern lens
but perhaps something very different
another big thing is that we have heard
that the Fantastic Four film might take
place in Another Universe not in our
main MCU Earth 616 Universe this is
rather exciting and it both makes sense
and is also kind of confusing at the
same time we're in the Multiverse Saga
right now we know incursions are going
to happen and we've already had a movie
that took place place a decent amount in
Another Universe Multiverse Madness in
the 838 Universe A Fantastic Four could
simply be like Multiverse of Madness but
reversed instead we could explore an
entirely different Universe for a good
majority of the film and then by the end
or maybe in parts we could see the main
MCU timeline and see the Fantastic Four
come into our main Universe perhaps
their universe is facing an incursion
and so is ours and they are colliding
into each other and this is where kind
of the confusing part comes into play
we'll talk about that in just a bit
first big thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you may
know that I personally use hellofresh
and I love it it makes cooking fun easy
and it's affordable and that's why it's
America's number one meal kit delivered
straight to your door and you might not
know that they actually have seasonal
recipes right now since it's summer they
have their new fresh and fit summer menu
so if you're trying to get that beach
bud but you're also trying to eat really
great tasting food it's perfect for you
right now it's Peak time for summer
produce and hellofresh make sure you get
all the best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now you can go to
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic for 50 off plus 15 off the next
two months that's hellofresh.com 50
Cosmic news code 50 Cosmic for 50 off
plus 15 off the next two months
so here is the unknown for the new
Fantastic Four reboot if it is going to
be set in Another Universe and they are
eventually going to cross over with our
main MCU Universe the same universe in
which the Avengers took place Age of
Ultron the Guardians of the Galaxy
Infinity war in game Etc all of phase
four and five and six if they are going
to cross into our universe and they are
going to be our main Fantastic Four team
from here on out what exactly happens at
the end of Secret Wars if they remain in
our main Universe it seems like their
Universe might actually be destroyed
otherwise why would they stay in our
universe however if that is the case
that means at the end of Avengers Secret
Wars the Damage Done To The Multiverse
might actually be permanent otherwise
why would the Fantastic Four not go back
to their own universe and if it was
destroyed that means they couldn't find
a way to restore it and this could have
really big implications for the MCU in
general moving forward after Secret Wars
many universes could Collide into one
there's also been talks of a soft Ruby
food happening in fact it looks like
that is most likely going to be the case
but how does that work with the new
Fantastic Four team we know Kevin feige
isn't going to introduce a Fantastic
Four team just to appear in one movie
and then in Avengers Secret Wars and
then be done we know that's not the case
we know they're sticking around for
phase seven and plenty of years after
that so they obviously are going to
survive this soft reboot and they're
obviously going to be in our main
Universe after that so the big question
is how what exactly happens at the end
of Avengers Secret Wars to keep them in
our main Universe only time will tell
for this but go ahead and give us your
best theories in the comments down below
now as far as everything that we know
about the cast so far is concerned again
it seems like Vanessa Kirby is our Sue
storm and it also seems like Marvel
Studios really really still wants Adam
Driver to be the Mr Fantastic of the MCU
currently our Two Front Runners for the
roll are Adam Driver and Matt Smith
according to multiple insiders including
Daniel rpk my time to shine hello and
many more Matt Smith is in the running
to play Mr Fantastic he has been given
an offer by Marvel Studios but Adam
Driver was also given an offer before
him which he declined he reportedly
declined the role because he couldn't
connect with the character via the
script however they have recently
written a new script and given him the
new script and are waiting to hear what
he says about the new script to see if
he maybe now wants to take on the
project to be Mr Fantastic of the
Fantastic Four and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now as far as the thing is
concerned the last thing that we heard
about who could possibly be playing him
is Ebon Moss boxrach he was in the
series Andor from Disney and he was also
in the Punisher for Netflix so he
definitely has connections with Marvel
Studios clearly Marvel and Disney like
him and right now he is the only name
out there right now to be in the running
for the thing and the Human Torch is
kind of still up in the air right now we
don't have any solid reports right now
in fact we have a lot of conflicting
reports about who the actor might be but
like I said since they are beginning to
test lenses to film the movie that means
the actual filming is not too far away
so we should know who our official
fantastic forecast is relatively soon so
go ahead and let us know your thoughts
about all of this in the comments down
below and who is your ideal fantastic
forecast which actors would you like to
see play which members let us know down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe stay up to date on all the
latest MCU and Fantastic Four News also
if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items winner picks one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month only three days left now so be
sure to subscribe and comment you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter as well
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign